freude herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen folge ein tag persönlicher koch
heute eben dass man gerne ins bild wir
starten einen leckeren komplett brot
avocado und tomate es komplett brot gibt
es auch noch einen bananen sheikh timo
sich gewünscht hat das sind alle
zusammen mir führt kay dachte ich mach
ein bisschen football mäßig habe ein
bisschen ben jerry's cookie dough rein
also mit einer cookie dough sheikh dazu
komplett brot und da ist einfach schön
eine scheibe posten mittel raus was
erwartet man doch erstmal ein bisschen
sagt geben einfach ein bisschen olivenöl
dran wie hält man schon mal eine pfanne
heiß 3 führte der letzte einfach mal und
da brauchen wir dann gleich auch ein
bruder schlecht beurteilt wie kann man
meist lächerlich ist nämlich das ding
hier da hat jetzt 3 1 wobei die sind so
klein da ich mach mit vier fahrzeugen
und elf mann wieder und die tomate
schneide ich jetzt in feine scheiben
nicht so dass sein pferd haben wir auch
gemacht was hier eigentlich nicht dass
man van leer jetzt in dem fall aber
schon wollte ich nicht dass die mutter
freund der jetzt noch zusätzlich hier
kurz auf der anderen hälfte des
plötzlich avocado knallen und
vorbereiten da wo gerade post mal wieder
und jetzt reduzieren wir die einfach und
ich habe mein geld da wenn man den kern
der rhein macht dann selbst die line up
frischen schreiben vor dass einige geben
das brot in den ofen und jetzt schnappen
wir das hier einen guten stich butter so
ungefähr 1 esslöffel dann schütten wir
rein
ab diesem zeitpunkt ab hoher hitze
einfach konstant umrühren uns irgendwie
diese textur könnt ihr es dann auch
ruhen lassen und jetzt bringt sie eben
an auf der unterseite durch zu backen
oben bleibt es oft im schnitt laufen
drin ein paar eine fein schneiden
hier sei es schön schon mal austoben
drauf und dann können wir schon mal
gucken dass wir das omelett von unten
lösen muss natürlich die beschichtung
erfahren auch für passen so also ich hab
das jetzt ein bisschen gelöst von unten
das heißt wir können jetzt auch schon
unsere fehlings quasi für das omelett
hineingeben tomate und kommt jetzt
unsere avocado und dann können wir jetzt
schon ganz behutsam wie eine ganze zu zu
klappen
darauf gebe ich noch ein wenig käse den
schmerz vielleicht noch ein bisschen an
das macht das ganze noch mal so ein
bisschen mehr mut planmäßig wir müssen
uns jetzt mit den bananen schlechter war
ein bisschen alt wird jetzt laut zeugt
noch ein bisschen milch natürlich dass
man sollte es immer mit flüssigkeit
machen
dann nehme ich mal zwei von diesen
bananen und da gehe ich jetzt wirklich
einfach so ein bisschen ab gefühlt
bisschen vanille zucker kamera gehe ich
jetzt einfach mal so einen guten
esslöffel und ein bisschen so da müssen
jetzt nur noch das brot anrichten an die
toten
ich gebe ein bisschen schmandt hier auf
die unterseite macht einfach noch mal
ein bisschen mund und dann auch schon
zeit komplett aufzugeben
jetzt noch den finishing touches an
schmelzen
immer wenn man dieses ding rausholen
der freunde vom aussehen chipkarten und
geschmacks experimentellen dort wo ich
noch nicht mehr irgendwas passt ja auch
wirklich und geschlecht probiert ich
habe schon früh steht leute weil bei dem
wetter
man habe ich noch nie gesehen spaß wie
creme fraiche weiß warum ich das erst
nach warum verschwand war bei uns so
eine beleidigung früher ja ja und dann
dachte ich immer dass mit der einigung
ist das schmeckt zustände und
mittelstand in eine gabel mit die kamera
aus okay wir sie jetzt gleich wieder
solo
du hast uns wirklich geschafft also ich
hab schon als erstes gab ja es gab schon
viele gäste die werden dabei klaren auf
jeden fall gescheitert hat sie denn
geschmeckt war so lecker wird sich also
als hätte nicht besser sein können oder
und banane sheikh als navarro
ja aber dieses cookie dough die habe ich
hier rein gemacht damit so ein bisschen
qualität schmeckt man ja nicht so dass
hausen hätte auch noch nicht
jetzt kommen natürlich die große frage
was heißt das in der not in der
bewertung
ich muss eine zehnte sagen weil es
wirklich ist es mein absolutes lieblings
früchte und du hast dass du perfekt
gemacht und ich will ich will mich nicht
beschweren über erzählt aber leute ich
habe extra ein werkzeug amtlichen
werkzeug in kauf für das mittagessen und
ihr seht jetzt was wir machen und hier
ist auch das gute stück es ist ein
reiskocher ich habe lange überlegt ob
ich mir einkaufen soll dann alles muss
ich reich gewünscht hat konnte ich gar
nicht anders
ich freue mich sehr darauf das
auszuprobieren wie essen das ganze mit
einem carey mit einem gelben curry kokos
mich ich habe die angie muss im
kühlschrank haltbar sind hähnchen kokos
curry mit reis kocht reis und ich glaube
es wird gut wir fangen aber erstmal in
den wipfeln
afrika
paprika einfach aus würfeln das ist
nicht perfekt sein
dann habe ich hier eine knoblauchzehe
und wird nämlich das gerieben eine
geraucht und ein wenig pop so alles
vorbereitet will dass man hier die
pfanne heiß werden ich gebe schon meine
mutter meine erdnussöl rein so da habe
ich jetzt hier so 400 gramm reis also
auf jeden fall eine ganze menge das was
ich jetzt drei mal und dann gebt den
reiskocher so ich gebe als aller erstes
mal die zwiebel hinein
hier ist unser reis das jetzt waschen in
den kopf hinein nur anschwitzen nicht
freuen
dann gebe ich hier auch schon caprica
dazu kaiser schoten brokkoli wird das
ganze welten anders und habe ich jetzt
hier schon mal zwei hühner brüste und
die schneide ich einfach in würfel so
wenn ihr alles an gewisse es gibt noch
ein wenig öl dazu dann kommt auch der
knoblauch sein sollte einfach nicht
drittletzter abgekommen und dann gehen
wir auch schon in kürze dazu falls
manche nicht wussten chilipulver ist
eigentlich kurkuma kreuzkümmel und
koriander also ein theater auf kuba auch
hier drauf schwitzens ein bisschen mit
an begehren das ganze trommeln und
halben teelöffel voll und dann gehen wir
noch ein bisschen currypulver wenn das
alles dran ist dann geben wir auch das
händchen dazu gelbe farbe ist auf jeden
fall jetzt schon gegeben und dann doch
alles schön durchgebraten ist dann gehen
tomaten also eine ganze dose gehackten
tomaten mädchen sein
dann können wir auch schon unsere
kokosmilch dazu geben weiß nicht genau
wie viel ich habe jetzt erst mal die
hälfte
und wer jetzt sehen wenn sich alles
verbindet und vermengt sondern auch so
diese töne geld ich fahre raus bekommen
kann man das ist einfach nur ein
bisschen köcheln lassen machen wir noch
ein bisschen pro kuh mal dran freuen ich
bin sehr gespannt der sollte jetzt
fertig sein ich öffne mal okay sieht gut
aus hat mir hier so eine tasche holt
dann trainiere ich das hier seht ihr es
ist angerichtet aus ich muss sagen also
ich hab schon mal ein restaurant
gegessen und so dass sie es ähnlich aus
ja ja ich hoffe er ist auch gut geworden
aber primär zurückhaltend das kind
innerhalb von einer minute wer also
wieder leute das wahlkampfleiter kann
immer so richtig schlecht schlägt sogar
weiß sehr viel ist wenn es spannend
geschmeckt hat also wer hat sehr gut
geschmeckt ja wir haben gerade schon ein
bisschen wir irgendwas ps irgendwann
irgendwas weil ich ich kann ja auch
nicht sagen was fehlt wahrscheinlich ist
das einfach so eine geheime zutaten aber
für mich ist es trotzdem
acht von zehn ok 18 für dich ich hätte
auch was gesagt zwischen 7 und 8 ist
halt sehr frische aber es fehlt dieses
gewisse etwas ich frage mich mal jemand
oder ihr habt vielleicht mein
geschmacksverstärker video gesehen ob
vielleicht das ist also ob da wirklich
aber an sich frösche nummer acht von
zehn wenn ich sehr zufrieden mit
abendessen wird auch sehr sehr lecker ja
freude kommt jetzt mal abendessen es
gibt für [ __ ] ein schönes rumpsteak dazu
crunchy potato wedges und einen
sommerlichen salat als kleiner beilage
klingt doch sehr gut ist auch glaube ich
nur der tag heute wirklich ein würdiges
ende wird das ganze wieder so wie zu
bereiten ihr kennt das ja mittlerweile
von mir verzeihen dass man schweizer
state ein luftdicht und zieht es dann im
wasserbad auf die gewünschte
kerntemperatur dadurch hat es genau den
indycars stücke die man will was jetzt
medien oder wie auch immer mag immer
perfekt das machen wir direkt als
allererstes weil da ist es garantiert
fertig wir mit dem rest der vorbereitung
durch sind
schnell verschleißt um die 2000 nichts
raus und so gegen besten ist ins wasser
oder das wasser wird jetzt erhitzt und
zirkuliert wir treffen schon mal das
steak nein sonst haben wir nichts mehr
damit zu tun das ist sehr gut weiter
geht es mit dem potato wedges sicher
probieren die zuzubereiten
so wie meine klassischen röstkartoffeln
aus dem ofen heißt es tut mir erstmal
aus den kartoffeln für eine große
portion alles so aus dass die registry
wir rausgingen ungefähr gleich groß sind
wird einfach für gleichmäßige ergebnisse
kann auch direkt eigentlich von den
backofen vorheizen auf 230 grad ober
unterhitze dann mach ich die noch mal
gut ab ich habe frischen rosmarin darin
werden nämlich die kartoffeln mit einem
kräuteröl machen so nice und ich fand
das dann auch noch von meinem balkon wo
es einfach fein hacken 2 knoblauchzehen
gegen auch bereit zum press werden in
das öl gleich aber erfuhren kümmern wir
uns erst mal um die kartoffeln auch wenn
es so aussieht keine sorge die sind
sauer jetzt und die viertel mehr einfach
dann haben wir so schöne drei matches
und so kommen wir jetzt gleich einfach
für zehn minuten vor
im topf mit kochendem wasser und
backpulver gesetzen schon ein viertel
päckchen backpulver kommt rein
jetzt schon das macht direct action dann
können wir auch schon unsere coaches
hinein droppen alex ertragen auch zehn
minuten gut salz dran
da kommt jetzt
rosmarin ein bis zum angetastet bei
rosmarie ist okay wenn es ein bisschen
heiß ist jetzt noch zu heiß für den
knoblauch da lassen wir jetzt einfach
die knoblauchzehen hinein
es ist eine gute ecke aber sollte
ehrlich das ist auch einfach das beste
nur ich glaube du liebst knobler genau
aufpassen dass der knoblauch keinen fall
brown wird jetzt schon mal von der
umstellung nächster schriftzügen sind
jetzt um mithilfe
wir treffen jetzt wieder das öl von
knoblauch in russland waren wir bis zum
schluss aus und fügen dann wieder eltern
zu
dafür ist jetzt auch unsere beteiligung
beckers hinzu zum ölpreis ist jetzt
details und jetzt kommt der pfarrer den
schatten der angst habe müsse nämlich
jetzt probiert die so ein bisschen durch
zu werfen die ecken sind alle nach plan
geht darum hier auch bei den kartoffeln
eben nicht in sotschi sind wie so eine
kleine lage von kartoffelbrei ausnahmen
zu machen weil die ist wie das ganze zu
frittieren das gute vorweg wir machen
auch und geben die fanpages drauf dass
wir nur dass sie gleichmäßig verteilt
sind und danach das ganze zu warten für
20 minuten sowie haben wir keine
kräuterbutter beziehungsweise hat die
hälfte von diesen ersten kräuter weil es
ein bisschen viel für die park getroffen
die wir hier haben
dazu schneidet ein viertel auf ihr
kleines einfach ganz fein schneiden dann
menge ich das bis in die butterseite
noch
dann haben wir auch schon unsere
selbstgemachte in kräuterbutter das habe
jetzt eine coole option sind durchkneten
durch mengen sehr kräuter ich auf jeden
fall ihr merkt schon wie heißt das hier
ist aber es muss sofort weg
deshalb werde ich die wir sind hier noch
mal hat sich dazu einen leckeren
sommerlichen salaten gewünscht und ich
habe ja später rucola erdbeere einfach
weiß jetzt gerade personal verfügbar ist
und das auch wirklich eine sehr schöne
abwechslung ist auf dem teller
die erdbeeren vierteln wir einfach
backtag und der väter blog bisschen viel
cola vielleicht dafür dass es eine
fusion ergeben soll aber das passt schon
wir sprechen hier einfach echte honig
frische kommt ja sowieso über den rhein
überqueren sagt ein anwalt es gibt zwei
anteile dann ohne buße ecke vom honig
draußen heißt übrigens schon der grill
fort weil es vielleicht geht es schlag
auf schlag des finnischen auch im
ferienclub kann man ein bisschen mehr
sein dass man auch mehr
von wem balsamico-essig kaufen kann
jetzt auch auf manche zitrone dran das
ist auch gut so fällt da schon auch dazu
durch werden dann ist das fertig auch
wenn die vertraut zu machen ein bisschen
dran und so restlichen kräuter dass das
auch für dich werfen könne jetzt ab und
in der zwischenzeit finnische ich das
lustig ist jetzt schön durchgezogen 30
bis 60 sekunden pro seite
[Musik]
mco fantastico da sitzt du vor dem
abendessen und setzten uns zusammen
ich bin gespannt ob sowie potato wedges
marx selbst gemachte kräuterbutter sowie
gegartes state noch nie gesehen erst
alert exotisch aber erstmal sind ja
gerade ist er sorgt braucht also
aussehen auf jeden fall top tobia meint
nur aufpassen amrum stick links ist ein
bisschen extra belassen
okay vielleicht dass auch gegessen und 1
200 vorbildlich ist glaube ich selbst
gar nicht mehr geschafft jetzt die
situation wegzuhauen aber sogar es
wirklich einen umzug das hinweg
gekleidet also ich hab mich auch das
habe ich auf das habe ich mich den
ganzen tag gefreut jetzt weiß ich habe
es wirklich nicht vergessen so ein
schönes steak ja kurz und knapp zehn
wirklich und ich muss sagen ich muss
einfach sagen man merkt ihr an dass du
daran sehr sehr viel spaß hast und das
ist wirklich eine große liebe von ihr
ist einfach und der küche zu stehen
bis man die kosten nicht mehr
das freut mich sehr die ich meine du
kannst es vielleicht auch ganz gut
beurteilen weil das letzte mal dass ich
für dich gefragt habe ich ja schon eine
ganze weile her und glaube auch dass ich
seitdem bisschen was getan hat zu lesen
weil ich mich aber etwas selbst
weiterentwickeln will
wir sehen uns nächsten donnerstag wieder
oder nächsten sonntag wenn sie da ist
ein persönlicher coach bis dahin macht
gut aber wir den kanal techno unbedingt
ab es war eine freude für mich zu kochen
weil ich glaube die hat nun wirklich an
gemerkt hat dass gefeiert das war geiler
tag